así quedó la unidad de cuidados
intensivos para pacientes con kobe 19
del hospital beehive ballack en india un
incendio arrasó con las instalaciones
desafortunadamente un gran incendio
ocurrió en nuestro hospital alrededor de
las 3 de la mañana faltan
o una chispa repentina del aire
acondicionado y como había más
suministros de oxígeno en la uci todo
terminó en dos minutos obteniendo plate
de ataque
domenech concluye de prolongar según los
reportes había 90 pacientes en el
hospital
poco después de desatarse la tragedia a
algunas personas que se encontraban en
las inmediaciones intentaron ayudar a
evacuar a los pacientes pero
lamentablemente no todos lograron salir
con vida
es un incidente muy doloroso y
desafortunado estos funcionarios están
aquí incluido el recaudador del distrito
el comisionado de policía y otros
funcionarios están ayudando a realizar
los traslados de 17 pacientes que
estaban en un sí han sido trasladados en
el primer ministro- narendra modi
lamentó lo sucedido el incendio de un
hospital kobe 19 en virar es trágico
condolencias a quienes perdieron a sus
seres queridos que los heridos se
recuperen pronto sin embargo esta
noticia no es una novedad en india ya
que se estima que 12.000 personas mueren
al año debido a siniestros en hospitales
que suceden en gran medida por el
precario estado de las infraestructuras
y por la falta de medidas de seguridad